[تصفيق]
افطار المطريه دور ليدي جاجا المنتظر في
الجوكر البروفيسور السوري اولى حلقات تحت
الوصايه والملكه كامله اليكم الابرز
الاسبوع الماضي
[موسيقى]
تفاعل متابعون مع الصوره التي نشرتها عبر
حسابها الرسمي على انستجرام من كواليس
فيلم الجوكر الجنون المشترك وتؤدي فيه دور
معالجه نفسيه تقع في حب البطل الذي يجسد
دوره مجددا فينكس واعلن المخرج دوت فيليبس
انتهاء التصوير والبدء بالعمليات الفنيه
استعدادا للعرض المنتظر
طيب
سينمائيا ايضا تصدر فيلم برايد الترند
عالميا على منصات التواصل وفي محركات
البحث مع اطلاق اعلان وبوسترات الفيلم
الرسميه وتدور احداثه حول الدميه الشهيره
باربي وتجسد شخصيتها الممثله ماركو تروبي
ومن المقرر عرضه اواخر يوليو المقبل
[موسيقى]
ومن عالم باربي الى العالم الحقيقي في مصر
المحروسه والصور المبهجه لافطار المطريه
احد احياء العاصمه المصريه الشعبيه والذي
اصبح حدثا سنويا منتظرا يحظى بتفاعل
واحتفاء كبيرين اعلاميا وعلى منصات
التواصل وبلغ طول المائده الرمضانيه التي
نظمها اهالي الحي نحو الف متر واحيو فيها
ذكرى الراحلين الذين شاركوا في تنظيم
الافطار خلال السنوات الماضيه واستضافوا
هذا العام مؤثرين وضيوفا من خارج البلاد
بحفاوه تعكس القيم المصريه الاصيله
ونبقى في اجواء رمضان حيث اقتتم موسم
العرض الرمضاني نصفه الاول الاسبوع الماضي
بعرض الحلقات الاخيره من ست مسلسلات مصريه
والمسلسل اللبناني السوري واخيرا انا بوت
ولكن
يسعد لي الله منتجات وخلال النصف الاول
حققت مسلسلات الهاشا السابعه وكامل العدد
ومذكرات زوج وهي اعمال اجتماعيه تدور حول
تحديات الحياه الزوجيه الافضليه على حساب
المسلسلات الاخرى وذلك بحسب ما عكسته
منصات التواصل من اصداء العرض وتفضيلات
الجمهور مع اشاده وتفاعل كبيرين مع
المسلسل الكوميدي الصفاره انا حاسس انه
اولادنا هم اصدقاء السوق اللي كانوا
اهالينا بيحزرونا منهم احنا عندنا واحد
غاوي حمام بنات واحد متنمر والثالث متحرش
سوريا وعربيا احتفى متابعه مسلسل الزند
ذئب العاصي بنجاح عاصي واصدقائه بالسطو
على البنك العثماني واعتبروا العمليه
النسخه العربيه من المسلسل الشهير لاكاسا
دي بابيل واعادت هذه الحلقه المسلسل
لدائره تفضيلات الجمهور مجددا الذي يتفاعل
على نحو المتزايد مع العمل اذا بدي شوف
حدا ممكن تبقى قرعته رح اقتلكم كلكم لو
سمحتوا وحظيت الحلقات الاولى من مسلسل تحت
الوصايه بالتفاعل الاكبر من متابعين منصات
التواصل كما حققت اولى حلقات جت سليمه
وتغيير جو تفاعلا لافتا مع انطلاقه النصف
الثاني من موسم العرض الرمضاني
واخيرا ومع اقتراب موعد مراسم تتويج الملك
تشارلز الثالث نشر الحساب الرسمي للعائله
الملكيه البريطانيه على انستجرام صوره
جديده للملك وزوجته كامله مستخدما لاول
مره وصف الملكه بدلا من الملكه القرينه
وبحسب احد المسؤولين في باكينغهام فان
التتويج هو الوقت المناسب لبدء استخدام
لقب الملكه كامله بصفه رسميه كما قال ان
لقب القرينه كان يستخدم لتجنب بعض
الارتباك بشان الملكه اليزابيث الثانيه
كما نشر الحساب الرسمي للعائله الملكيه
البريطانيه صوره للدعوه الرسميه لمراسم
التتويج من تصميم اندرو جيمسون تم رسمه
يدويا وسيتم اعاده انتاجه وطباعته لالفي
ضيف مدعو بحسب الحساب الذي نشر ايضا صورا
لعدد من دعوات التتويج التاريخيه من
الارشيف الملكي